ласкаво повертайся до курсу «Розуміння квантової інформації та обчислень», мене звати Джон Вотус, і я технічний директор з освіти
в IBM Quantum. Це дев'ятий урок серії і перший урок третього розділу, який присвячений загальній
формулюванню квантової інформації. До цього моменту ми використовували спрощене формулювання
квантової інформації, де квантові стани представляються комплексними векторами з евклідовою нормою, рівною
одиниці. Натомість у загальному формулюванні квантової інформації квантові стани представляються
матрицями певного типу, відомими як матриці густини. Цей перший урок розділу зосереджений саме на матрицях густини —
ми розберемося, що вони таке і як вони працюють у ході уроку. Матриці густини надзвичайно
корисні й мають різні переваги, про які ми поговоримо. Вони дозволяють нам представляти
ширший клас станів, ніж вектори квантових станів, — включаючи стани систем, на які вплинув шум, наприклад, а також випадкові
вибірки квантових станів. Ми також розглянемо сферу Блоха, яка дає нам дуже зручний
і простий геометричний спосіб мислення про стани qubit, і побачимо, як вона пов'язана з матрицями густини
досить вражаючим чином — через матриці Паулі. Нарешті, ми обговоримо матриці густини в контексті кількох
систем і, зокрема, побачимо, як вони дозволяють нам описувати квантові стани систем, що розглядаються ізольовано, навіть якщо
вони корельовані з іншими системами, — включаючи можливість того, що вони заплутані з іншими системами. Це важлива річ —
вміти це робити, і це нелегко зробити в рамках спрощеного формулювання квантової інформації. Ось огляд
уроку: ми почнемо з основ матриць густини, включаючи відповідні означення та деякі приклади,
а також обговоримо, як вони пов'язані з векторами квантових станів. Потім поговоримо про опуклі комбінації матриць густини, або,
іншими словами, що відбувається, коли ми беремо зважені середні матриць густини. Почнемо з конкретного
прикладу так званого повністю змішаного стану. Ми побачимо, як класичні ймовірнісні стани можна розглядати як
окремі випадки матриць густини, і обговоримо, як спектральна теорема з лінійної алгебри відіграє роль у
цьому контексті. Третя частина уроку присвячена сфері Блоха, яка надає геометричний спосіб перегляду станів
окремих qubit, як я згадував на початку уроку. У четвертій частині уроку ми поговоримо про те, як матриці густини працюють для кількох
систем. Ми обговоримо добутні стани та корельовані стани різних типів, включаючи заплутані стани, а також
поняття редукованого стану — опису матрицею густини стану ізольованої частини складеної системи,
яку можна обчислити за допомогою операції, відомої як частковий слід. Перш ніж перейти до технічного змісту самого уроку,
варто витратити кілька хвилин, щоб пояснити доцільність використання матриць густини. Використовуючи спрощене
формулювання квантової інформації, яке не включає матриці густини, ми можемо описувати квантові алгоритми, як-от
алгоритм факторизації Шора, наприклад, без жодних труднощів. То навіщо ж тоді займатися матрицями густини
або цим загальним формулюванням квантової інформації взагалі? Є кілька причин. По-перше, матриці густини
представляють ширший клас квантових станів, ніж вектори квантових станів, — включаючи квантові стани, де є невизначеність або
випадковість. Це важливо, коли ми хочемо моделювати вплив шуму на квантові обчислення,
наприклад. По-друге, використовуючи матриці густини, ми можемо описувати квантові стани ізольованих частин складених систем, як-от
стани систем, заплутаних з іншими системами, які, можливо, тимчасово ми вирішуємо ігнорувати. Як я згадував на початку
уроку, це непросто і неприродно зробити в рамках спрощеного формулювання квантової
інформації. Третя причина полягає в тому, що коли ми використовуємо матриці густини, класична інформація фактично з'являється як
окремий випадок. Тому замість того, щоб мати, по суті, аналогію між ймовірнісними станами й операціями, з одного боку,
та векторами квантових станів і унітарними операціями — з іншого, ми маємо квантову і класичну інформацію,
описані разом у рамках єдиного математичного формалізму, що є практично обов'язковим для математичного вивчення
квантової інформації. Тож якщо ти серйозно налаштований зрозуміти квантову інформацію на математичному рівні, дуже
рекомендується вивчити матриці густини. Почнемо з означення матриць
густини. Для потреб означення припустимо, що X — це система, а sigma — її множина класичних станів, і нагадаємо, що
коли ми використовуємо цю термінологію, ми припускаємо, що Sigma є скінченною і непорожньою, і, як завжди, ми можемо вибирати
різні назви за бажанням. Матриця густини, що описує стан системи X, — це матриця з комплексними
числовими елементами, рядки та стовпці якої поставлені у відповідність з її множиною класичних станів. І, щоб бути точним,
ця відповідність однакова для рядків і стовпців одночасно. Це означає, що матриці густини
завжди є квадратними матрицями. Крім того, щоб бути квадратними, необхідно виконати ще кілька умов,
до яких ми незабаром перейдемо. Зазвичай для позначення матриць густини використовують певні малі грецькі літери:
ро — найпоширеніший вибір, інші поширені варіанти — мала сигма та тау, які показані
на екрані. Це лише умовність, але, як завжди, такі умовності корисні, бо роблять речі більш
легко впізнаваними. А тепер поговоримо про умови або вимоги, яким повинні задовольняти матриці густини, щоб бути
коректними матрицями густини. Їх дві, і я спочатку просто перелічу їх,
а потім докладніше поясню, що вони означають. Перша умова полягає в тому, що матриці густини
повинні мати одиничний слід, тобто слід, рівний одиниці. Друга умова полягає в тому, що
матриці густини повинні бути позитивно напіввизначеними. В обох випадках є стислі символічні способи вираження
цих двох умов, які показані на екрані. Тепер докладніше обговоримо обидві умови.
Перша умова стосується сліду — дуже важливої функції, визначеної для всіх квадратних матриць,
яка є просто сумою діагональних елементів. Ось рівняння, яке виражає це
явно. Про слід можна сказати чимало, і про те, чому він важливий, але поки що зауважимо лише
одну дуже базову його властивість: він є лінійною функцією. Інші властивості сліду виникатимуть і будуть обговорюватися в міру
необхідності, але, щоб зосередитися на матрицях густини, перейдемо до другої вимоги — вимоги того, що
матриці густини є позитивно напіввизначеними. Це також важливе поняття, що виникає в багатьох контекстах у
WEBVTT
фізиці, хімії, оптимізації, машинному навчанні та інших дисциплінах. Його можна виразити кількома різними, але
еквівалентними способами. Один спосіб — сказати, що матриця ро є позитивно напіввизначеною, якщо існує матриця M
така, що ро дорівнює M†M. І виявляється, що не має значення, вимагаємо ми, щоб M сама по собі була
квадратною матрицею, чи ні. Інший спосіб виразити, що матриця ро є позитивно
напіввизначеною — сказати, що ро є ермітовою, тобто рівною своєму спряженому транспонуванню, і всі її
власні значення є невід'ємними дійсними числами. Загалом ермітові матриці можуть
мати лише дійсні власні значення, але вони можуть бути від'ємними. Якщо ж додати обмеження, що жодне з
власних значень не може бути від'ємним, ми отримаємо позитивно напіввизначені матриці. До речі, якщо тобі дана
матриця і ти хочеш знати, чи є вона позитивно напіввизначеною, можна визначити це за допомогою цієї характеристики. Досить легко
перевірити, чи є матриця ермітовою — це можна зробити, просто подивившись на неї. Складніше обчислити
власні значення, але це не надто складно зробити на комп'ютері, оскільки для цього існують дуже ефективні алгоритми.
Остання характеристика, яку я згадаю, — хоча є й інші — полягає в тому, що для кожного стовпчикового вектора s, кількість
елементів якого узгоджується з кількістю рядків і стовпців матриці ро, нерівність, показана на
екрані, є істинною. Іншими словами, bra s, помножений на ро і помножений на ket s, повинен бути невід'ємним дійсним
числом. Між іншим, не очевидно, що всі ці характеристики еквівалентні, але вони є. Зауважу явно, що
позначення, яке ми зазвичай використовуємо, щоб вказати, що матриця ро є позитивно напіввизначеною, виглядає як «ро більше
або рівне нулю», але це лише скорочене позначення, і це буквально не означає, що ро більше або рівне
нулю. Ро — це матриця, тому таке твердження не мало б сенсу. І це не означає,
що кожен з елементів ро більший або рівний нулю. Зокрема, існують позитивно
напіввизначені матриці, елементи яких не всі невід'ємні, і є матриці, всі елементи яких невід'ємні,
але при цьому не є позитивно напіввизначеними. Ідея за позначенням полягає в тому, що позитивно напіввизначені
матриці є ніби матричними аналогами невід'ємних дійсних чисел, але це лише позначення, і те, що воно означає —
це саме те, що ми вже обговорили. Тепер розглянемо кілька прикладів, починаючи з прикладу
позитивно напіввизначеної матриці. Насправді досить легко випадково згенерувати приклад
позитивно напіввизначеної матриці, просто довільно вибравши матрицю M і потім обчисливши M†M.
Наприклад, ось матриця M, яка не є особливо спеціальною, і насправді
я згенерував цю матрицю випадково, незалежно обираючи дійсну та уявну частини елементів цілими числами між мінус 9 і плюс
9. Тож будь-які закономірності чи структури тут є суто випадковими. Помноживши
спряжено транспоновану матриці M на M, ми отримаємо ось цю матрицю, яка, отже, є позитивно
напіввизначеною. Звісно, є межа того, наскільки глибоко ми можемо зрозуміти щось із випадкового прикладу, але він все ж демонструє деякі
риси, характерні для позитивно напіввизначених матриць загалом. Зокрема, ти помітиш,
що діагональні елементи — тобто ті, що знаходяться вздовж лінії від верхнього лівого до нижнього правого кута — всі є невід'ємними дійсними
числами. Більш того, позадіагональні елементи якось не є надто великими порівняно з відповідними діагональними
елементами — тобто тим, що знаходиться в тому самому рядку і в тому самому стовпці, що й позадіагональний елемент, який ми розглядаємо.
Проте в цій темі є ще більше, і важливо розуміти, що бути позитивно напіввизначеною — це
властивість матриці як цілого, а не просто умова на окремі елементи. Отже, це приклад
позитивно напіввизначеної матриці, і ти можеш дуже легко генерувати інші приклади за аналогічною
методологією. Тепер розглянемо деякі приклади матриць густини, де, на додачу до умови позитивної напіввизначеності, ми також маємо, що слід
рівний одиниці. Ось кілька прикладів матриць густини розміром 2×2. Слід рівний
одиниці у всіх чотирьох випадках, і ми також бачимо, що це ермітові матриці. Тому, використовуючи другу характеристику
позитивно напіввизначених матриць, що залишається — це перевірити, що всі власні значення невід'ємні.
Залишаю це тобі для самостійної перевірки, якщо хочеш. Для матриць 2×2 не надто складно обчислити власні значення вручну,
але можна попросити комп'ютер зробити це. Наприклад, можна використати функцію eigvals у пакеті лінійної алгебри
для Python. Ми також можемо отримати матрицю густини, просто взявши будь-яку ненульову
позитивно напіввизначену матрицю і поділивши її на її слід. Наприклад, ось матриця густини, яку ми отримаємо,
розділивши приклад, що ми бачили щойно, на його слід. Ділення на слід ось так
завжди зберігатиме властивість позитивної напіввизначеності, і ми, безумовно, отримаємо матрицю зі слідом, рівним одиниці, завдяки тому, що
слід є лінійною функцією. Це лише невелика добірка прикладів, і ми побачимо більше в міру того, як
урок триватиме. Далі ми витратимо лише кілька хвилин, щоб обговорити інтерпретацію або
інтуїтивне значення матриць густини. Перше, що варто визнати: може здатися трохи незвичним,
що ми представляємо стан системи матрицею, а не вектором. Натомість у спрощеному
формулюванні квантової інформації ми використовуємо вектори для представлення станів, тоді як матриці, зокрема унітарні матриці,
представляють дії або операції. Так просто влаштована математика, і хоча ти
завжди можеш думати про матриці як про лінійні відображення, ми зазвичай не пов'язуємо прямого інтуїтивного
значення з лінійним відображенням, асоційованим з певною матрицею густини. Утім, той факт, що
матриці густини є справді матрицями, виявляється критично важливим їхнім аспектом, і ми побачимо
це в міру того, як продовжуватимемо. Щоб навести лише один приклад наразі: власні значення певної матриці густини
виявляються дуже важливими, оскільки вони описують, скільки випадковості або невизначеності властиво стану,
який описує ця матриця густини. Інший спосіб думати про матриці густини на інтуїтивному рівні
зосереджується на елементах цих матриць. Пам'ятай, що рядки і стовпці матриць густини поставлені
у відповідність з класичними станами будь-якої системи, про яку ми говоримо. Тому для кожного елемента є один
класичний стан, що відповідає рядку того запису, і один класичний стан, що відповідає стовпцю того
запису; для діагональних записів ці два класичні стани є одним і тим самим станом — ось чому діагональні записи є
особливими, і один зі способів інтерпретувати діагональні записи полягає в тому, що вони є ймовірностями, а конкретно —
ймовірностями того, що відповідний класичний стан з'явиться, якщо ми виконаємо вимірювання у стандартному базисі
системи, квантовий стан якої ми описуємо; для позадіагональних записів, з іншого боку, є один класичний стан, що відповідає рядку
того запису, і інший класичний стан, що відповідає стовпцю того запису, і дуже неформально кажучи,
ці записи описують ступінь, у якому ці два класичні стани перебувають у квантовій суперпозиції, а також
відносну фазу між ними; це може стати зрозумілішим, коли урок продовжиться і ми розглянемо
деякі конкретні приклади ближче, і деталі можуть бути неочевидними на цьому етапі, але, будь ласка, не дозволяй цьому тебе турбувати —
це досить неформально і є лише інтуїтивною ідеєю, яку варто тримати в голові;
далі ми розглянемо зв'язок між матрицями густини та векторами квантового стану, які є стовпцевими
векторами з евклідовою нормою, рівною одиниці; просто щоб пригадати математичне визначення: припустимо, що маємо
вектор квантового стану s, що представляє стан певної конкретної системи; матриця густини, яка представляє той самий
квантовий стан, задається як Ki помножене на brasai, як показано тут на екрані; щоб було зрозуміло: індекси Sai
певним чином відповідають класичним станам тієї системи, про яку ми говоримо, і це буде рівно той самий зв'язок між
рядками і стовпцями нашої матриці густини та класичними станами системи; якщо уявити, що є n
класичних станів системи, і ми думаємо про стовпцеві та рядкові вектори як про матриці, тоді Ki — це матриця N на один,
а Brasi — матриця 1 на n; отже, виконавши множення, ми отримаємо матрицю N на n;
ця матриця завжди буде додатно напіввизначеною матрицею вже за своєю формою, і вона також матиме слід, рівний
одиниці, завдяки тому, що s є одиничним вектором, і ми розглянемо це детальніше
незабаром; квантові стани, що представлені матрицями густини такої форми, називаються чистими
станами; ось кілька прикладів: спочатку розглянемо цей стан
ось тут, який є чимось на кшталт стану плюс, за винятком того, що запис, що відповідає класичному стану один,
є уявним; якщо ми обчислимо спряжену транспоновану, то отримаємо мінус, оскільки комплексне спряжене від i є
мінус i; і якщо ми виконаємо множення, отримаємо матрицю, показану тут на екрані; вона є ермітовою, як ми можемо
одразу побачити просто поглянувши на неї, і виявляється, що вона має одне власне значення, рівне одиниці, і одне власне значення, рівне
нулю; отже вона є додатно напіввизначеною, і її слід рівний одиниці, тому це є матрицею густини, як
й очікувалося; ми можемо аналогічно обчислити матриці густини для стандартного базису та базисів плюс-мінус, і ті матриці густини
показані тут; і ось ще один приклад вектора квантового стану —
він з'явився ще на першому уроці цієї серії; якщо ми обчислимо спряжену транспоновану, а потім помножимо,
ми отримаємо матрицю густини, показану тут; знову вона є ермітовою і має
слід, рівний одиниці; і якщо обчислиш власні значення, то знову побачиш, що одне власне значення рівне одиниці, а одне
власне значення рівне нулю; до речі, це є загальною характеристикою всіх чистих станів — вони завжди мають одне власне значення,
рівне одиниці, а всі інші власні значення рівні нулю; загалом для довільного вектора квантового стану
s з будь-якою кількістю записів: якщо ми множимо Ki на brasai, ми отримаємо
матрицю густини, що виглядає ось так; зверни увагу зокрема на те, що діагональні записи завжди є одним із
записів s, помноженим на його власне комплексне спряжене, що ми можемо альтернативно виразити як квадрат абсолютного значення того запису, і це
один зі способів побачити, що слід завжди буде рівний одиниці; це також узгоджується із зауваженням, яке я зробив раніше на уроці про те, що
діагональні записи матриці густини показують нам, які ймовірності побачити кожен можливий класичний стан,
якщо ми виконаємо вимірювання у стандартному базисі; і останнє зауваження:
з матрицями густини немає жодних проблем, пов'язаних із глобальними фазами; два квантові стани є ідентичними тоді і лише тоді, коли їхні матриці
густини рівні; зокрема, припустимо, що ми маємо два вектори квантового стану s та fi, які
є еквівалентними з точністю до глобальної фази, тобто ми можемо виразити один із них fi, скажімо, через інший помножений
на деяке комплексне число на одиничному колі; якщо ми обчислимо матричне представлення густини fi, тоді ми
побачимо, що множник глобальної фази множиться на своє власне комплексне спряжене, і це дає нам одиницю, тому він
фактично зникає і ми отримуємо рівно ту саму матрицю густини, що й від s; тобто це такий приємний маленький бонус, і загалом немає жодних
проблем, пов'язаних із еквівалентністю з точністю до глобальних фаз, коли ми
працюємо з матрицями густини; це лише виродженість, яка існує, коли ми використовуємо вектори квантового стану, а не
матриці густини для представлення квантових станів; матриці густини мають ключову властивість, яка полягає в тому, що опуклі
комбінації матриць густини представляють імовірнісні або випадкові вибори квантових
станів; інший спосіб це сказати — що матриці густини можна усереднювати разом значущим чином, чого
не можна зробити з векторами квантового стану; щоб пояснити це детальніше, почнімо з ситуації, в якій
у нас є дві матриці густини row та sigma, що представляють квантові стани деякої системи; уявімо, що
система підготовлена у стані row з імовірністю P для деякого вибору P між нулем і одиницею, і інакше
система підготовлена у стані Sigma; наприклад, можливо p дорівнює 1/2, тому
ми можемо уявити, що хтось підкидає монету, і якщо орел — він виконує деякий процес, що залишає систему у
стані row, а інакше, якщо монета випала решкою, він виконує інший процес, що залишає систему у
стані Sigma; питання тепер таке: що є станом системи? і щоб бути точним,
нас цікавить стан системи в ізоляції, нехтуючи будь-якою іншою інформацією, яка може існувати про
те, яка підготовка була виконана; наприклад, уявімо, що у нас немає доступу до монети або
пам'яті того, хто виконував підготовку стану; і відповідь на це питання полягає в тому, що це просто зважене середнє двох матриць
густини P * row плюс 1 - P * Sigma; це, до речі, є повністю
аналогічним до того, що ми мали б, якби row та sigma були не матрицями густини, а векторами ймовірностей,
що представляють імовірнісні стани; тому це не є чимось шокуючим або таємничим, а навпаки —
це щось, можливо, знайоме з теорії ймовірностей; ми постійно виконуємо таке усереднювання, коли обчислюємо ймовірності й думаємо
про класичні випадкові вибори; і суть у тому, що це також працює для матриць густини, але зверни увагу, що це
не працює для векторів квантового стану, тобто ти зазвичай не можеш усереднити два вектори квантового стану
ось так і сподіватися отримати допустимий вектор квантового стану; якщо спробуєш, ти зазвичай отримаєш вектор,
який не має евклідової норми, рівної одиниці; з матрицями густини, однак, зважені середні ось так завжди будуть
допустимими матрицями густини, і що важливіше — матриця густини, яку ти отримаєш, представлятиме той випадковий вибір
значущим чином; це узагальнюється на випадкові вибори з більш ніж двома
альтернативами; зокрема, якщо ми маємо M можливих матриць густини та вектор ймовірностей з M записами, по одному
для кожної матриці густини, і система підготовлена у кожному можливому стані з відповідною ймовірністю,
тоді зважене середнє тих матриць густини описує результуючий стан системи; і до речі, коли ми
посилаємось на опукле поєднання матриць густини, ось що ми маємо на увазі: опукле поєднання — це просто лінійна
комбінація, де коефіцієнти утворюють вектор ймовірностей; це завжди буде матрицею
густини, і простий та стислий спосіб сказати це математичними термінами — що множина всіх матриць густини,
що відповідають даній системі, є опуклою множиною; отже, якщо ми маємо, скажімо, m векторів квантового стану
size 0 по S M мінус один разом із ймовірностями p 0 по p m мінус один, що разом утворюють
вектор ймовірностей, і система підготовлена у стані s k з імовірністю PK для кожного k, тоді
результуючий стан системи описується матрицею густини, показаною тут на екрані; зокрема, ми не усереднюємо
самі вектори квантового стану, а натомість усереднюємо відповідні матриці
густини; загалом такий стан не матиме представлення як єдиний вектор квантового стану,
якщо не відбувається щось тривіальне, наприклад, усі вектори квантового стану є еквівалентними з точністю до глобальної фази або всі, крім одного, з
ймовірностей рівні нулю; ми не отримаємо чистий квантовий стан від такого процесу; натомість ми отримаємо те, що
називається змішаним квантовим станом, де є деяка внутрішня невизначеність; розглянемо простий
приклад: припустимо, що ми маємо qubit і з імовірністю 1/2 qubit підготовлено у стані нуль, а інакше
він підготовлений у стані плюс; ось матриця густини, яку ми отримаємо через усереднювання, як я
описав: ми обчислюємо матриці густини для двох можливих станів, множимо на відповідні ймовірності і додаємо
результати; те, що ми отримуємо, справді є матрицею густини: вона ермітова, її слід рівний одиниці,
і якщо ти обчислиш власні значення цієї матриці, ти отримаєш два додатних дійсних числа, і виявляється, що це два числа, які мають тобі бути
зараз знайомі: косинус у квадраті від pi/8 та синус у квадраті від pi/8, або приблизно 0,85 та
0,15; не існує єдиного векторного представлення квантового стану — це не чистий стан; далі ми розглянемо одну
конкретну матрицю густини, що представляє квантовий стан одного qubit, відому як повністю змішаний
стан; цей стан часто зустрічається, тому добре мати для нього назву, і це також гарний приклад, оскільки він
ілюструє важливу особливість матриць густини; насправді існує аналогічно визначений повністю змішаний стан для будь-якої
системи, але зараз ми зосередимось на цьому стані для одного qubit, щоб усе залишалось
простим; припустимо, що ми випадково встановлюємо стан qubit як стан нуль або стан один, кожен із
ймовірністю 1/2 — подібно до рівномірного випадкового біту; ми можемо обчислити матричне представлення густини цього
стану звичайним способом: ми беремо середнє двох матричних представлень густини станів; ось як
це виглядає у матричній формі, і що ми отримуємо — це одинична матриця, поділена на
два; цей стан відомий як повністю змішаний стан, і він в основному представляє повну або максимальну
невизначеність щодо qubit — подібно до того, як рівномірний вектор ймовірностей представляє максимальну невизначеність у
класичному імовірнісному контексті; загалом для довільної системи повністю змішаний стан —
це стан, який ми отримуємо, рівномірно вибираючи стан стандартного базису, і матричне представлення густини буде
одиничною матрицею, поділеною на розмірність або, еквівалентно, на кількість класичних станів тієї
системи; поки що це лише термінологія, але якщо ми трохи змінимо налаштування, побачимо важливу особливість
матриць густини; зокрема, припустимо, що ми змінюємо процедуру і на
місце стандартних базисних станів нуль і один підставляємо стани плюс і мінус; цього разу ми починаємо з
виразу, показаного на екрані, але якщо ми виконаємо арифметику, ми отримаємо рівно ту саму
матрицю густини: це одинична матриця, поділена на два; тобто це той самий стан, що й раніше —
повністю змішаний стан; це, як кажуть, особливість, а не помилка; дві процедури є насправді
різними, але якщо у тебе є лише результуючий qubit, немає фізичного способу їх розрізнити —
навіть у статистичному сенсі; наприклад, якщо ти виконаєш вимірювання у стандартному базисі цього qubit
після першої процедури, ти, очевидно, отримаєш результат нуль з імовірністю 1/2 і результат один з імовірністю 1/2, але ти також отримаєш
рівно ті самі ймовірності виходів для другої процедури, і те ж саме справедливо для будь-якого іншого тесту, який ти можеш
придумати, за умови, що ти тестуєш лише сам qubit; загалом матриці густини не описують, як система була
підготовлена — вони лише говорять тобі, що відбудеться, якщо ти щось робитимеш із системою в подальшому, чи то виконуватимеш
операції, чи вимірювання; і насправді матриці густини є ідеальними в цьому
відношенні: якщо дві різні альтернативи призводять до однієї матриці густини, вони не можуть бути розрізнені навіть
статистично; але якщо дві матриці густини є різними, тоді буде якийсь спосіб їх розрізнити —
не обов'язково остаточно, але у статистичному сенсі; коли ми використовуємо загальне формулювання квантової
інформації, класична інформація по суті виникає як окремий випадок, і зараз я поясню, як це
працює; зокрема, ми побачимо, як імовірнісні стани можуть бути представлені матрицями
густини; почнімо з класичних станів, починаючи з простого
прикладу: ось матричні представлення густини для стандартних базисних станів нуль та один
qubit; ми пов'язуємо ці стани з класичними станами 0 та один, тому ми можемо думати про ці матриці густини як
про представлення цих станів; це дуже просто, і ми можемо легко узагальнити
приклад: якщо ми маємо систему, класична множина станів якої є Sigma, то класичний стан a представлений або
пов'язаний із матрицею густини k a bra a; та матриця має один на діагональному
записі, рядок і стовпець якого відповідають класичному стану a, і кожен інший запис є
нулем; імовірнісні стани представлені опуклими комбінаціями матриць такої форми, що є природним
з огляду на те, що ми знаємо про матриці густини та їхню роботу; зокрема, що опуклі комбінації матриць густини представляють випадкові або
імовірнісні вибори квантових станів; наприклад, припустимо, що ми маємо
систему X, класична множина станів якої включає цілі числа від 0 до n мінус один для деякого додатного цілого числа n;
звісно, втрата загальності є незначною або відсутньою при припущенні, що наша класична множина станів має таку форму; якщо ми мали б
іншу класичну множину станів, ми могли б просто перейменувати класичні стани таким чином, і це часто досить зручно — припускати, що наші
класичні множини станів мають такий вигляд, значною мірою тому, що це полегшує явний запис речей через
вектори та матриці; припустимо, що у нас є імовірнісний стан системи X,
представлений вектором ймовірностей звичайним чином; ми можемо пов'язати цей імовірнісний стан з матрицею
густини, як показано на екрані: ми беремо зважене середнє матриць густини, що відповідають
різним класичним станам, і те, що ми отримуємо — це діагональна матриця густини; зокрема, ми бачимо ймовірності
вздовж діагоналі цієї матриці, і кожен інший запис рівний нулю; звичайно, це є матрицею густини —
ми очікуємо, що це буде так, але ми також можемо обгрунтувати це безпосередньо: це ермітова матриця, її слід
рівний одиниці, оскільки ймовірності у сумі дають одиницю, і у випадку діагональної матриці власні значення є діагональними
записами, і вони всі є невід'ємними, оскільки вони є ймовірностями; також зверни увагу, що кожна
діагональна матриця густини, тобто та, у якої всі позадіагональні записи рівні нулю, повинна виглядати ось так; тому в двох словах:
імовірнісні стани можуть бути пов'язані з діагональними матрицями густини; зверни увагу до речі, що це узгоджується з
неформальною інтерпретацією записів матриць густини, яку я згадав на початку уроку; зокрема, нічого не перебуває у
квантовій суперпозиції — тут по суті є лише класична випадковість, і відповідно всі позадіагональні
записи є нулями; раніше в цій серії ми обговорювали спектральну теорему, і зробили це
конкретно для унітарних матриць у контексті фазової оцінки; спектральна теорема є більш
загальною, однак, тобто вона говорить нам щось про ширший клас матриць, ніж лише унітарні
матриці, і зокрема вона застосовується до класу матриць, що називаються нормальними матрицями, які включають усі матриці
а також унітарні матриці; що ми зробимо зараз — це розглянемо іншу постановку цієї теореми, цього разу зосередившись лише на
додатно напіввизначених матрицях, а потім ми побачимо, що вона говорить нам щось дуже цікаве і надзвичайно важливе про матриці
густини; припустимо, що p — це будь-яка додатно напіввизначена матриця, тобто це включає будь-яку матрицю густини, а також будь-яку
додатно напіввизначену матрицю, яка не має сліду, рівного одиниці; p є додатно напіввизначеною, тому вона має бути
квадратною, тобто N на n для деякого вибору N, і нам потрібно буде посилатися на це число n, тому нехай N буде
вибрано відповідно; інший спосіб все це сказати — припустити, що p є n на n; що теорема говорить нам у цьому випадку —
так це те, що повинен існувати ортонормальний базис векторів, які ми назвемо s0 по S мінус один, разом із невід'ємними дійсними
числами Lambda 0 по Lambda мінус один, такими що p можна виразити, як показано
тут на екрані; словами: якщо ми множимо кожен Lambda K на Kai k * brasai K, а потім
підсумовуємо по всіх K від 0 до n мінус один, ми отримаємо P; це називається спектральним
розкладанням P; кожен Lambda K є власним значенням p, і кожен s є одиничним власним вектором P,
що відповідає цьому власному значенню; якщо ти повернешся до уроку 7 про фазову оцінку, ти знайдеш подібну теорему
для унітарних матриць; там власні значення є комплексними числами на одиничному колі, а не невід'ємними дійсними
числами, але в іншому це та сама ідея; і це є лише два окремих випадки більш загальної теореми, відомої як
спектральна теорема; вона не працює для кожної матриці — матриця має комутувати зі своєю
власною спряженою транспонованою, і саме це означає, що матриця є нормальною; але насправді ми завжди маємо
це і для унітарних матриць, і для додатно напіввизначених матриць, і для ермітових матриць більш загально, де
ми завжди матимемо дійсні власні значення, але не обов'язково невід'ємні; отже, це є формулювання
спектральної теореми лише для додатно напіввизначених матриць, і тепер давай подивимось, що вона говорить нам про матриці
густини; те, що вона нам говорить — для довільної матриці густини n на n ми завжди можемо виразити ту матрицю як опукле
поєднання n чистих станів, і більше того, ми можемо взяти ці n чистих станів
ортогональними; це досить безпосередньо випливає з теореми разом із базовим фактом лінійної алгебри, а саме що
сума власних значень будь-якої матриці завжди рівна сліду тієї матриці; іншими словами, все, що ми насправді
робимо тут — це перейменовуємо власні значення p 0 по PN мінус один, і потім зауважуємо, що коли ми робимо це і
збираємо ці власні значення в n-вимірний вектор, ми обов'язково отримуємо вектор ймовірностей, оскільки вони всі мають бути невід'ємними і їхня сума рівна
сліду row, який є одиницею, оскільки row є матрицею густини; отже, це досить просто, але це є
справді фундаментальним концептуально; те, що це нам говорить — що кожна матриця густини, незалежно від
того, наскільки складною вона може здаватися, могла б виникнути спочатку через вибір ортонормального базису тієї системи,
про яку ми говоримо, а потім випадковий вибір квантового стану з того базису згідно з деяким вибором ймов-
-ірностей; якщо з першого погляду не зрозуміло, чому це є цікавим або важливим — нічого страшного, але ми використовуємо цей
факт дуже часто, коли міркуємо про матриці густини, і насправді вираження даної матриці густини
у такий спосіб часто є самим першим, що ми робимо, коли хочемо зрозуміти її
краще; ось приклад: пригадай матрицю густини, яку ми отримали раніше, де ми випадково вибирали між
станом нуль та станом плюс, кожен із ймовірністю 1/2, яка, як ми обчислили, має матрицю густини, що
виглядає ось так; стан нуль та стан плюс не є ортогональними, тому це не є
спектральним розкладанням; але якщо ми обчислимо одне — а це можна зробити за допомогою комп'ютера або вручну в такому випадку — то що ми
отримаємо, це такий вираз нашої матриці густини, де власні значення — це ті числа, що постійно з'являються, і
де відповідні власні вектори можна обрати, як показано тут внизу на екрані; і знову ми бачили ці вектори раніше, наприклад у
контексті гри chsh на уроці четвертому; отже, це цікаво: згідно з
початковим виразом, цей стан є тим, що ми отримуємо, рівномірно вибираючи між двома станами: станом нуль та
станом плюс; але насправді ми отримуємо рівно ту саму матрицю густини, випадково вибираючи між двома чистими
станами, але дуже сильно схиляючись до одного з них — близько 85% для першого і лише близько 15% для
другого; отже, в деякому сенсі в стані насправді є значно менше випадковості, ніж могло спочатку здаватися;
існує дуже гарний геометричний спосіб думати про квантові стани одного qubit і візуалізувати їх, відомий
як сфера Блоха; він працює лише для одиночних qubit — для систем, що мають три
або більше класичних станів, включаючи два або більше qubit разом, він більше не працює; тому він є досить обмеженим, але
тим не менш це чудовий спосіб думати про стани одного qubit; його можна було б представити ще
на першому уроці серії про одиночні системи, але він не є дійсно необхідним для розуміння того, як працює квантова інформація, і він також має
справді гарний зв'язок із матрицями густини, тому він природно вписується в цей урок; і насправді я збираюся пояснити
його дещо інакше, ніж це, мабуть, найтиповіше пояснення, — використовуючи матриці густини для того, щоб фактично
вивести його; отже, якщо ти вже знайомий зі сферою Блоха, це пояснення може трохи відрізнятись від того,
як ти вперше дізнався про неї, але в кінцевому підсумку воно, звичайно, має бути еквівалентним; ми почнемо з роздумів про
можливі чисті стани qubit спочатку, як представлені векторами квантового стану;
з точністю до глобальної фази кожен вектор квантового стану qubit можна виразити,
як показано тут на екрані; точніше кажучи, ми маємо два дійсних числа Theta та fi, і ми будемо думати
про ці два числа як про кути, виражені в радіанах; перше число Theta знаходиться між 0 та Pi, або еквівалентно — це кут
між 0 та 180°, а друге число fi знаходиться між 0 та 2 pi, включаючи 0, але не 2;
pi; тобто це будь-який кут між 0 та 360°; нульовий запис нашого вектора —
косинус від theta / 2, тобто дійсне число між 0 та 1, і зокрема воно є обов'язково невід'ємним;
а одиничний запис нашого вектора — це e в степені I * 5 помножене на синус від th / 2, і це може бути
будь-яким комплексним числом на або всередині комплексного одиничного кола; це завжди є одиничним вектором, або
іншими словами, допустимим вектором квантового стану; і для будь-якого заданого вектора квантового стану qubit ми завжди можемо знайти
вектор такої форми, що є еквівалентним до того вектора з точністю до глобальної фази; зокрема, ми завжди можемо
помножити даний вектор на глобальну фазу, щоб зробити нульовий запис невід'ємним дійсним числом; обрати будь-яке
Theta, що дає нам той запис, а потім підібрати fi так, щоб воно відповідало одиничному запису; величина одиничного запису завжди
обов'язково збігатиметься зі значенням синуса від theta ділене на два за умови, що ми починали з одиничного
вектора; тепер не зовсім так, що Theta та F однозначно визначаються тим вектором квантового стану, з якого ми почали,
але це майже так; завжди буде унікальне значення theta між нулем та Pi, яке підходить,
і зазвичай є унікальне значення fi, яке підходить, але в двох особливих випадках це не так; зокрема, якщо ми починали зі стандартного
базисного стану, тоді Theta буде або нуль, або pi, і в обох випадках насправді не має значення, яке fi — воно є
абсолютно неважливим; коли Theta рівне нулю, косинус від theta / 2 рівний 1, а синус від theta / 2
рівний нулю, тому ми множимо e в степені I * F на нуль, тому не має значення, яке fi;
і якщо Theta дорівнює pi, тоді цього разу косинус рівний нулю, а синус рівний одиниці, тому ми маємо e в степені I * 5 * kat1, але ті
вектори всі є еквівалентними з точністю до глобальної фази, тому знову не має значення, яке fi; однак якщо Theta лежить строго
між нулем та Pi, тоді завжди буде унікальне значення F, яке підходить; і до речі, ця можлива
виродженість у значенні fi для двох особливих випадків матиме ідеальний сенс, коли ми побачимо геометричну картину —
зовсім скоро; а тепер давай обчислимо матрицю густини, пов'язану з вектором стану тієї форми, яку ми щойно
визначили; отже, це буде чистим станом qubit; щоб це зробити, ми множимо вектор
на його спряжену транспоновану, як зазвичай, і на екрані показано вираз матриці, яку ми отримуємо, обчислюючи
спряжену транспоновану і виконуючи множення; тепер, як і кожна матриця 2x2,
існує унікальний спосіб отримати цю матрицю, взявши лінійну комбінацію матриць Паулі,
включаючи одиничну матрицю; зокрема, ми можемо отримати цю матрицю, вибравши коефіцієнти
матриць Паулі, як показано тут на екрані; ми ставимо двійку в знаменник, оскільки це
змусить усе гарно скластися; ніщо нас не змушує це робити, але ми можемо, і це виявиться корисним; але окрім
цього косметичного вибору, ніякої свободи тут немає — це єдиний спосіб отримати цю матрицю, взявши лінійну комбінацію матриць Паулі;
це тому, що матриці Паулі разом із одиничною матрицею є базисом для векторного простору всіх матриць 2x2; один зі способів
перевірити правильність цього виразу — скористатися деякими базовими тригонометричними тотожностями, і зокрема якщо я відступлю убік на
мить, ось тотожності, які справляться з цим завданням; отже, якщо хочеш — постав відео на паузу або
зроби знімок екрана і спробуй отримати другий вираз матриці густини знизу з першого; отже, підсумовуючи: будь-який чистий стан
qubit, виражений як матриця густини, може бути записаний як лінійна комбінація матриць Паулі, як показано тут на
екрані для Theta між 0 та pi та F між 0 та 2 pi; зверни увагу, що ми маємо рівно ту саму
виродженість, що й раніше, а саме: fi є неважливим, коли Theta дорівнює або нулю, або pi, і цього разу ми можемо насправді
побачити це більш чітко, тому що синус від theta дорівнює нулю в обох цих випадках, а в іншому — ні; варто звернути
увагу на те, що в цій формулі Theta виступає як аргумент функцій синуса і косинуса, а не Theta / 2, як у початковому векторі квантового стану
у векторному записі — і це тому, що ми використали ті тригонометричні тотожності, перші три з яких є по суті
перетвореннями так званих формул подвійного кута, тому кут фактично подвоюється; і ось нарешті ми готові
поговорити про саму сферу Блоха; давай зосередимося на трьох коефіцієнтах при матрицях Паулі, що не є одиничними,
у чисельнику виразу для нашої матриці густини, тобто ми нехтуємо двійкою в
знаменнику; ми також нехтуємо одиничною матрицею, тому що коефіцієнт при нійніколи не змінюється — це відбувається тому, що
той коефіцієнт визначається слідом тієї матриці, яку ми виражаємо, а матриці густини завжди мають слід, що дорівнює
одиниці; тепер уяви, що в нас є три осі, позначені x, y і z, орієнтовані відповідно до
так званого правила правої руки, і розглянемо точку, координати якої збігаються з трьома коефіцієнтами; і щоб бути точним —
ми говоримо про звичайний тривимірний простір, де координати завжди є дійсними числами;
координата x відповідає коефіцієнту матриці Паулі sigma X у чисельнику нашого виразу, яка завжди є дійсним числом, оскільки матриці густини
є ермітовими; і те саме стосується Y та Z; ми з'ясовуємо, що ця точка,
яку ми отримуємо, завжди лежить на одиничній сфері, або іншими словами — на сфері з радіусом, що дорівнює
одиниці; і зокрема, це точка, яку ми отримаємо, якщо почнемо з точки, де позитивна вісь z перетинає сферу,
що можна уявити як Північний полюс, повернемося вниз до позитивної осі x на кут theta, а потім
повернемося до позитивної осі y, або іншими словами — на схід, на кут fi; у цьому контексті кут Theta
називається полярним кутом, що легко запам'ятати, бо він починається від полюса, а F називається азимутальним
кутом; і разом ці два кути являють собою сферичні координати точок на одиничній сфері; і якщо
захочеш — ти також можеш дозволити радіусу змінюватись, щоб представити довільні точки в тривимірному просторі, але тут ми зосереджуємось на точках на
одиничній сфері, де радіус дорівнює одиниці; ти також можеш думати про Theta як про широту, за винятком того, що ми йдемо
від 0 до 180° від Північного полюса до Південного, а не плюс-мінус 90° від екватора; а F представляє
довготу, де ми по суті визначаємо нульовий меридіан як меридіан, що перетинає позитивну
вісь x; якщо ти, як і я, маєш труднощі з тим, щоб пам'ятати, що таке широта і що таке довгота, то може бути корисним пам'ятати,
що довгота відповідає інтервалу, який є довшим — 2 pi, на відміну від
pi; так чи інакше, точка, яку ми отримуємо на одиничній сфері з нашого вектора стану qubit, розмірковуючи про координати таким
чином, є представленням на сфері Блоха квантового стану, що відповідає саї; і коли ми думаємо про всю
тривимірну одиничну сферу в такий спосіб, ми отримуємо сферу Блоха; геометрично це просто одинична
сфера у звичайному тривимірному просторі, але фактично це і є геометрія станів
qubit; тут є ідеальна взаємно однозначна відповідність: кожен чистий стан qubit відповідає унікальній точці на
сфері, і кожна точка на сфері представляє унікальний стан qubit з точністю до глобальної фази; коли ми працюємо з
векторами квантового стану, ця відповідність, до речі, має й інші назви — її також іноді називають сферою Пуанкаре,
наприклад; але в контексті квантової інформації її зазвичай називають сферою Блоха; зверни увагу, що тепер ми можемо побачити
виродженість у куті fi досить чітко, тому що довгота не має сенсу на Північному та Південному полюсах; але окрім
полюсів кожна точка на Землі має унікальні координати з точки зору широти та довготи, і те саме відбувається тут; отже, ось як
сфера Блоха працює загалом; тепер давай розглянемо кілька конкретних прикладів станів qubit та
того, де вони знаходяться на сфері Блоха; почнемо зі стандартного базису — це точки, які ми отримуємо,
коли полярний кут Theta дорівнює нулю для стану нуль і pi для стану один; це два випадки, де
азимутальний кут fi є неважливим, як я вже обговорював; ми також можемо виразити відповідні матриці густини як лінійні
комбінації матриць Паулі; в будь-якому разі ми робимо висновок, що ці два стани відповідають Північному полюсу та
Південному полюсу сфери Блоха: стан нуль знаходиться зверху, а стан один —
знизу; далі знайдемо стани плюс і мінус на сфері Блоха; знову ж таки, ми можемо думати або про
вектори квантового стану, або про матриці густини; для векторів квантового стану цього разу полярний кут Theta має бути pi
/ 2, щоб нульовий запис був рівний 1 / sqrt(2); азимутальний кут F має бути нульовим
для стану плюс, оскільки одиничний запис є додатним для стану плюс; і він має бути pi або 180° для стану мінус,
оскільки там він є від'ємним; отже, ці дві точки лежать на
екваторі сфери Блоха: стан плюс — там, де позитивна вісь x перетинає сферу, а стан мінус — з протилежного боку, де
негативна вісь x перетинає сферу; еквівалентно, це також видно з виразів через матриці Паулі для
відповідних матриць густини: координати Y і Z обидві нульові, тоді як координати x є додатною і від'ємною
одиницею; ще один приклад — базис плюс I мінус I, який є подібним до базису плюс-мінус, за винятком того, що ми також множимо
одиничний запис на I — уявну одиницю; стан плюс I ми бачили раніше на уроці, а стан мінус I визначається
аналогічним чином; полярний кут Theta такий самий, як і для станів плюс і мінус — pi /
2; і цього разу нам потрібно обрати азимутальний кут F так, щоб отримати I та від'ємне I, а не 1 та від'ємне 1;
і pi / 2 та 3 pi / 2 — правильний вибір для цього; знову ж таки, ми можемо також розглянути
описи цих станів через матриці густини, і все досить схоже до попередніх двох прикладів, за винятком того, що цього разу замість
Z або X стоїть матриця Паулі Y; тож на сфері Блоха ці два стани розташовані там, де вісь y
перетинає сферу; і якщо трохи упорядкувати, можна чіткіше побачити, як ці шість станів, які ми щойно обговорили,
пов'язані між собою; ще для одного прикладу, або насправді класу прикладів, розглянемо
вектори стану qubit, що виникали раніше на уроці четвертому, де нульовий запис — косинус від alpha для деякого дійсного числа alpha, а одиничний
запис — синус від alpha; до речі, ми можемо обмежити увагу значеннями alpha між нулем та pi, оскільки будь-яке
інше значення alpha дасть нам вектор, еквівалентний з точністю до глобальної фази тому, де alpha знаходиться в цьому
діапазоні; якщо ми обчислимо матриці густини, пов'язані з цими станами, виражені як лінійні комбінації матриць Паулі,
ми отримаємо вираз, що показано тут на екрані; ці обчислення тут не наведені, але саме те,
що ти маєш отримати, якщо пройдеш через них; і ми з'ясовуємо, що ці стани утворюють так зване велике коло, яке проходить
через полюси: починаючи з Північного полюса, коли alpha дорівнює нулю, йдучи вниз по нульовому меридіану та
досягаючи Південного полюса, коли alpha дорівнює pi / 2, а потім повертаючись до Північного полюса з протилежного боку сфери, поки alpha змінюється від pi / 2 до
pi; і все це має сенс, тому що, по-перше, це дійсні вектори, тож уявна частина завжди нульова, а по-
друге, кут alpha фактично подвоюється на сфері Блоха; і знову це можна пояснити використанням
формул подвійного кута; ми бачили, що сфера Блоха дає дуже гарне геометричне представлення для чистих станів
qubit, де кожна точка на сфері відповідає унікальному чистому стану qubit і навпаки;
коли ми говоримо про кулю Блоха, ми маємо на увазі всі точки на сфері Блоха, а також точки,
що містяться всередині неї; точки в інтер'єрі кулі Блоха також відповідають станам
qubit — зокрема станам, які не є чистими; іншими словами, це стани qubit, які можна представити матрицями густини, але не векторами стану
qubit; фундаментальний аспект кулі Блоха та того, як внутрішні точки представляють нечисті стани, полягає в тому, що
опуклі комбінації точок всередині кулі Блоха відповідають опуклим комбінаціям матриць густини;
інтуїтивно це означає, що геометрія продовжує працювати бездоганно навіть всередині кулі
Блоха; давай розглянемо кілька прикладів, починаючи з центральної точки кулі Блоха, яка представляє
повністю змішаний стан; повністю змішаний стан отримується шляхом усереднення станів нуль і один, що узгоджується з тим фактом,
що центр сфери знаходиться рівно посередині між Північним і Південним полюсами; і фактично він знаходиться посередині між будь-якими двома антиподальними точками, такими як
стани плюс і мінус та стани плюс I і мінус I; антиподальні точки на сфері Блоха завжди відповідають
ортогональним чистим станам; і це розкриває або відображає той факт, що ми завжди можемо записати повністю змішаний стан
як середнє між будь-якими двома ортогональними чистими станами qubit; ще один спосіб побачити це —
подумати про представлення через матриці Паулі для повністю змішаного стану; щоб це спрацювало, нам потрібно встановити
коефіцієнти при всіх трьох матрицях Паулі, що не є одиничними, рівними нулю; тому відповідна точка всередині
кулі Блоха знаходиться прямо в центрі — в початку координат; і до речі, думка про представлення матриць густини через матриці Паулі
насправді досить чітко показує, що опуклі комбінації точок кулі Блоха відповідають опуклим
комбінаціям матриць густини; якщо ми беремо середнє або зважене середнє матриць густини та
виражаємо все через лінійні комбінації матриць Паулі, то, звичайно, ми просто усереднюємо відповідні точки, тому що все
є лінійним відносно тих трьох коефіцієнтів; ще для одного прикладу розглянемо середнє стану нуль
та стану плюс, яке ми бачили раніше на уроці; ми обчислили представлення через матрицю густини, що показано на
екрані, і ми маємо, що точка знаходиться всередині кулі Блоха — рівно посередині між станом нуль і станом плюс;
ми також бачили, що можемо виразити цю матрицю густини інакше — на основі її спектрального розкладання;
і знову це узгоджується з діаграмою та попередніми прикладами; і на цьому
обговорення сфери Блоха та кулі Блоха завершено; люди часто запитують, чи існує сфера Блоха або куля Блоха для систем, що мають
три або більше класичних станів; і, на жаль, відповідь — не зовсім; ми завжди можемо думати про
квантові стани системи в геометричних термінах, подібних до кулі Блоха, і ми отримаємо опукле тіло у дійсному векторному
просторі; але якщо ми маємо три або більше класичних станів, воно не буде сферичним; наприклад, якщо ми маємо
рівно три класичних стани, або кутрит коротко, ми отримаємо опукле тіло у восьмивимірному
просторі; але крайні точки цього тіла, які відповідають чистим квантовим станам кутриту, утворюватимуть лише
чотиривимірний многовид; якщо ти можеш візуалізувати чотиривимірний многовид у восьмивимірному просторі та якось обернути його щільно, щоб отримати опукле
тіло — і знаходиш це корисним способом думати про кутрити, то, гадаю, добре для тебе; це цікаво
подумати, але це не куля — це набагато складніше; в останній частині уроку ми коротко обговоримо,
як матриці густини працюють для кількох систем; матриці густини можуть представляти стани кількох систем, і це
працює цілком аналогічно до векторів квантового стану; зокрема, так само, як і в спрощеній формулюванні квантової
інформації, ми можемо розглядати кілька систем разом, ніби вони є однією складеною
системою; цього разу як рядки, так і стовпці матриць густини, що представляють стани кількох систем,
ставляться у відповідність декартовому добутку наборів класичних станів окремих систем; наприклад, ми можемо розглянути
представлення чотирьох станів Белла через матриці густини, які ми отримуємо точно так само, як і для інших векторів квантового
стану раніше на уроці — множачи вектори стану на їхні спряжено-транспоновані; і результати показано тут на
екрані; по суті, тут нічого нового на концептуальному рівні немає, хоча за мить ми побачимо, що є деякі
нові речі, які ми можемо робити з матрицями густини для кількох систем; поняття незалежності та
кореляцій переходять від векторів квантового стану до матриць густини; і зокрема, тензорні добутки
матриць густини представляють незалежність між системами; ми використовуємо ту саму термінологію, що й
для векторів квантового стану; наприклад, якщо ми маємо систему X, підготовлену в стані row, і систему Y,
незалежно підготовлену в стані Sigma, то стан пари XY разом задається тензорним добутком
row та sigma; ми називаємо це продуктовим станом, і це природно узагальнюється на більше ніж дві
системи; матриці густини, які не можна виразити як продуктові стани, представляють кореляції між системами, і ця
частина подібна до векторів квантового стану; але, як виявляється, існують різні типи кореляцій, які можуть виникати, коли ми використовуємо матриці густини, навіть для
двох систем; на відміну від цього, для векторів квантового стану є дійсно лише один тип кореляцій, який ми можемо мати,
а саме — заплутаність; іншими словами, кореляція та заплутаність є синонімами для векторів квантового стану, але
це не так для матриць густини; тут все цікавіше; наприклад, ми можемо описувати
корельовані класичні стани за допомогою матриць густини; ось приклад матриці густини, що представляє класичний випадковий
біт, яким ділиться Alice та Bob; вони завжди мають однаковий класичний стан — нуль або один, і ймовірність
1/2 для кожного з варіантів; це не є заплутаним станом — заплутаність є некласичною, але
це є корельованим станом; ще один приклад пов'язаний з поняттям ансамблю квантових станів,
про який ти можеш думати як про розподіл ймовірностей над скінченним набором квантових станів; зокрема, уяви, що
у нас є M матриць густини row від нуля до row від M мінус один — всі вони представляють можливі стани певної системи,
разом з ймовірністю вибрати кожну з них; якщо захочеш — ти можеш обчислити зважене середнє цих матриць густини,
взявши їхню опуклу комбінацію; але це насправді не скаже нам, якими були окремі стани або якими були
ймовірності; що ми можемо зробити натомість — і це іноді дуже корисно — це розглянути матрицю густини
виду, показаного тут на екрані; це стан двох систем, де перша система має один класичний
стан для кожної з альтернатив, і ми беремо зважене середнє M продуктових станів, де стан
першої системи є завжди класичним і по суті позначає, який із M станів ми маємо для другої
системи; якщо не зовсім зрозуміло, навіщо нам думати про такі стани, — нічого страшного; це просто приклад
типу кореляції, де перша система є завжди класичною, а друга система може перебувати в квантовому
стані; третя категорія можливо корельованих станів — це набір так званих сепарабельних
станів; простими словами, це опуклі комбінації продуктових станів, і вони по суті представляють квантові
стани, де будь-які кореляції між системами є класичними кореляціями; один спосіб думати про
такі стани — це те, що ми робимо імовірнісний вибір числа K, а потім незалежно готуємо дві
системи в квантовому стані, що може залежати від цього вибору K; мабуть, найцікавіше в
станах такої форми — це те, що саме так ми визначаємо заплутаність у математичних термінах; зокрема, заплутаність —
це відсутність сепарабельності; тобто, якщо ти маєш матрицю густини і неможливо виразити її у формі,
подібній до цієї, то за визначенням вона є заплутаною; я натякав на це ще на уроці четвертому, і тут це
в дещо більших подробицях; до речі, може бути дуже важко визначити, чи представляє дана матриця густини заплутаний
стан — навіть за допомогою комп'ютера; математично та обчислювально кажучи, заплутаність —
це насправді досить складна річ; я згадував на початку уроку, що є дуже важлива річ, яку ми можемо робити з матрицями густини, а
саме — описувати стани ізольованих частин систем, навіть коли вони корельовані та можливо заплутані з іншими
системами; термін «редукований стан» часто використовується в цьому контексті; і як простий приклад ми обчислимо редуковані
стани для окремих qubit, що утворюють ebit; точніше, припустимо, що
Alice та Bob ділять ebit: Alice тримає qubit A, Bob тримає qubit B, і разом ці два qubit перебувають у стані fi
плюс; і питання, яке ми розглянемо, — який є стан qubit A Alice
в ізоляції; звичайно, ми могли б поставити те саме питання для qubit Bob, але відповісти на нього легко, знаючи відповідь на це
запитання; тепер може виникнути спокуса сказати, що ми не можемо описати стан qubit Alice в ізоляції, тому що він
заплутаний з qubit Bob, що може якось забороняти нам описувати або навіть думати про стан A в
ізоляції; але це хибно; справді, ми не можемо описати стан A вектором квантового стану,
тому що, як ми побачимо, він не перебуває в чистому стані; але кожна система має стан у будь-який момент, який може бути
описаний матрицею густини — незалежно від того, чи вона заплутана з іншою системою чи ні; як уявний експеримент, щоб
допомогти нам побачити, яка є відповідь на це питання, припустимо, що Bob вирішує взяти свій qubit і вирушити до зірок, і від нього
більше немає вісток; але уяви, що десь на шляху він вирішує виконати вимірювання в стандартному базисі на своєму
qubit; ну, ми знаємо, як обчислити ймовірності для двох можливих результатів, і ми також знаємо, яким буде
стан A для кожного можливого результату; і ці речі підсумовані в цій таблиці; зокрема, з ймовірністю 1/2
A залишиться в стані нуль, і з ймовірністю 1/2 A залишиться в стані один; тому, як обговорювалось раніше на
уроці, це залишає A у повністю змішаному стані; і тому це є відповіддю
на наше питання; тепер ти можеш заперечити і сказати, що це залежить від факту,
що Bob вирішив виміряти свій qubit, і припущення про те, що він це робить, є частиною розповіді, яка привела нас до цієї відповіді; але
якщо Bob знаходиться за світлові роки, коли він вимірює, — ніщо з того, що він робить, не може мати жодного впливу на будь-який
експеримент, який Alice може вирішити провести на своєму qubit, — інакше ми б мали зв'язок швидше
за світло; тому qubit Alice перебуває в повністю змішаному стані незалежно від того, чи вимірює Bob
свій qubit чи ні; варто уточнити, що поняття редукованого стану та спосіб його визначення насправді не залежать від теорії відносності
або неможливості зв'язку швидше за світло; це просто спосіб пояснити це в, сподіваюсь, інтуїтивно зрозумілих термінах;
насправді існує математичне визначення, яке ми побачимо в більш загальному контексті за мить; воно узгоджується з цією відповіддю
і, до речі, з неможливістю зв'язку швидше за світло; і немає іншого
визначення, яке могло б бути узгодженим з квантовою інформацією, як ми її знаємо; тепер давай розглянемо редуковані стани в більшій
загальності; припустимо, що ми маємо пару систем A і B, не обов'язково qubit, які разом перебувають у чистому стані,
представленому вектором квантового стану s; знову ми зосередимося на редукованому стані системи A, і для цього
нам буде корисно думати про класичні стани системи B; тож нехай гамма — це цей набір
класичних станів B; як ми обговорювали раніше, зокрема на уроці другому серії,
існує унікальна сукупність векторів f b для кожного B в гамма, для яких вираз s, показаний на екрані,
є правильним; і зокрема, існує проста формула для цих векторів: ми просто множимо вектор s на
тензорний добуток одиничної матриці, що відповідає системі A, з бра B — для того B, який нас цікавить;
що ми тут робимо — це по суті готуємо ґрунт для обчислення того, що станеться, якщо ми виконаємо
вимірювання в стандартному базисі на B; і знову це розглядалось на уроці другому
серії; тому, якщо ми виконаємо вимірювання в стандартному базисі на B, кожен можливий результат буде з'являтися
з ймовірністю, рівній квадрату евклідової норми відповідного вектора fi b, і за умови отримання
конкретного результату B ми нормалізуємо вектор fi B, щоб визначити результуючий стан
A; слідуючи тому самому міркуванню, що й у прикладі з ebit кілька хвилин тому, ми отримуємо вираз, показаний на
екрані, для редукованого стану A як матриці густини; і до речі, квадрат норми в знаменнику виникає від
множення нормалізованого вектора на його спряжено-транспоновану, тому ми маємо евклідову норму двічі в
знаменнику; квадрати евклідових норм скорочуються, і ми отримуємо досить простий
вираз; і фактично, якщо ми підставимо нашу формулу для fi B, яка виконується для кожного B, ми отримаємо формулу для редукованого
стану системи A через опис матрицею густини чистого стану, з якого ми починали, а саме — псі
бра псі; отже, це наша формула для редукованого стану системи A за умови, що складена система AB починала в
чистому стані псі; але ми також можемо використовувати формулу в більш загальному вигляді; зокрема, припустимо,
що стан AB задано деякою матрицею густини row, яка може мати вигляд K псі бра псі для деякого вектора квантового стану
псі, але не обов'язково; з цього випливає, по суті завдяки лінійності, що редукований стан A визначається
тією самою формулою, що й для чистих станів, за винятком того, що ми підставляємо будь-яку матрицю густини row,
яку хочемо; як скорочений запис, досить поширено позначати цей редукований стан тією самою назвою, що використовується для
матриці густини row у цьому випадку, але з нижнім індексом, що вказує на систему, на якій ми зосереджуємось; тому row з нижнім
індексом A означає редукований стан A, коли складена система перебуває в стані row; іноді замість нижніх індексів
використовуються верхні — це по суті особиста перевага, і означає те саме
саме; ми зосереджувались на системі A лише для простоти, але ми можемо також отримати редукований стан системи B
аналогічно, де формула адаптована природним чином; все тут є симетричним — ми
по суті просто міняємо місцями ролі A та B; і зокрема, сума тепер ведеться по класичних станах A, а не
B; і у формулі на екрані ми припускаємо, що набір класичних станів A називається
Sigma; все це узагальнюється досить прямолінійним чином на три або більше системи; наприклад, якщо ми маємо три
системи A, B і C, які разом перебувають у стані, описаному матрицею густини row, то ми можемо отримати
редукований стан пари A разом за формулою, показаною тут, а також стан третьої системи окремо —
за другою формулою; і ти можеш розглядати інші комбінації та узагальнювати це на скільки завгодно систем; суми завжди беруться по
наборам класичних станів систем, які ігноруються, і патерн завжди однаковий: матриця густини,
з якої ми починали, затискається між тензорним добутком одиничної матриці та бра та кет, що відповідають стандартному базисному
стану; на завершення уроку я скажу ще трохи про означення, які ми щойно розглянули; операція над матрицями густини,
що описує редуковані стани, має назву, і вона називається частковим слідом; для двох систем A і B
частковий слід по B та частковий слід по A визначаються так, як показано тут на екрані; це рівно ті самі
формули, що ми бачили кілька хвилин тому, і тепер ми просто думаємо про них як про функції від row та даємо їм
назви; назви виглядають як слід, але з нижнім індексом, що вказує, яка система видаляється,
або іншими словами — яка система є тією, по набору класичних станів якої ми підсумовуємо і яка затискається між бра та
кет; коли ми беремо частковий слід нашого B, наприклад, що описується першою формулою, ми іноді кажемо, що
B відстежується, і так само для A; інтуїтивно кажучи, відстеження системи
просто означає, що ми відкидаємо її або просто ігноруємо; це один спосіб визначити частковий
слід; а ще один еквівалентний спосіб — сказати, що ці відображення є єдиними лінійними відображеннями, що задовольняють
формулам, показаним тут справа; зокрема, якщо ми маємо тензорний добуток двох матриць M та N, скажімо,
і ми виконуємо частковий слід по першій системі, то ми отримуємо слід першої матриці M, помножений на
другу матрицю; і умова є симетричною, коли ми беремо слід по другій системі; не кожна матриця, від якої ми обчислювали б частковий слід, є тензорним добутком такого виду, але кожна матриця може бути виражена як лінійна комбінація
тензорних добутків, і ми можемо визначити частковий слід з цих умов разом із тим фактом, що ці є лінійними
функціями; і саме тому це називається частковим слідом; це еквівалентне визначення може бути
досить корисним, тому що ми часто можемо використовувати його замість початкової формули; ось приклад, що
ілюструє це; припустимо, що ми маємо пару qubit A у стані, матриця густини якого показана тут на
екрані; це, до речі, приклад корельованого стану, де A або перебуває в стані нуль, або в стані один — кожен
з ймовірністю 1/2; отже, можна думати про A як про класичний; якщо A у стані нуль, то
і B у стані нуль; а якщо A у стані один, то B перебуває в стані плюс; якщо ми хочемо знати, яким є редукований стан A,
ми беремо частковий слід по B; і якщо ми використаємо другу формулу з еквівалентного визначення разом з лінійністю, то можемо
обчислити це досить легко; зокрема, слід від k0 бра 0 дорівнює одиниці, як і слід від K плюс бра
плюс; тому ті тензорні множники зникають, і ми залишаємось з повністю змішаним станом; аналогічним чином ми можемо обчислити
редукований стан B, беручи частковий слід по A; цього разу перший тензорний множник є тим, від якого ми беремо слід, тому
ми використовуємо першу формулу з еквівалентного визначення; і ми залишаємось з 1/2 * кет 0 бра 0 плюс 1/2 * кет
плюс бра плюс, або іншими словами — та сама матриця густини, що виникала кілька разів раніше; ти б отримав рівно ті самі
результати, якби скористався формулами з першого визначення, але це набагато простіший спосіб це зробити; все це узагальнюється на три або більше
систем, але для цього відео я зупинюсь тут і залишу це для самостійного розгляду; і на цьому — все для цього уроку, який
ввів матриці густини та описав основи того, як вони працюють; ми також обговорили сферу Блоха,
а також різні типи кореляцій та поняття редукованого стану системи; сподіваюсь, ти приєднаєшся до мене на
наступному уроці, який присвячено каналам — лінійним відображенням із матриць густини в матриці густини, що
описують операції над системами; до побачення на
наступному уроці; бувай до
зустрічі